imagine this you're a researcher with an
interest in and an aptitude for marine
biology
over the years your work has taken you
far and wide
to the furthest corners of the earth's
oceans you've observed countless species
of sea life
from fish and crustaceans to whales and
sharks
predators and prey alike during one of
your travels
you find yourself off the coast of south
africa monitoring the local population
of sea creatures
looking out across the water you see a
large dark shape moving below the
surface
there is a shadow streaking its way
towards your vessel dark as night
speeding
like a torpedo you rush across the deck
leaning over the port side as the shape
swims beneath
your boat you're certain you know what
it was
after all your years studying the world
beneath the waves you know a whale shark
when you see one
the largest known species of fish still
in existence the whale shark is a filter
feeder
consisting on a diet of plankton and
other tiny aquatic organisms
a whale shark poses absolutely no threat
to humans
or rather any whale shark other than
this one would impose a threat
but how could you know that scanning the
water you strain your eyes trying to
spot what you assumed was an ordinary
whale shark swimming below
but there is nothing no sign of it
anywhere
saying you think you've might have
missed your chance to see one in the
wild
perhaps it changed direction instead of
swimming under the boat you tell
yourself
the ship turns and starts making its way
back towards the small harbour
leaving you blissfully unaware that
there's an extra passenger on board
as you disembark you notice something on
the side of the boat
emblazoned on the whole is a motif of a
familiar shape
a whale shark depicted entirely in
painted dots
you stare at it for a moment intrigued
by the pattern
it reminds you of a piece you once saw
an aboriginal australian style of dot
art
you're a little taken aback by the
coincidence having briefly spotted a
whale shark while out at sea
earlier blissfully unaware that this
painting marks your first encounter with
scp-1449
known more colloquially as the dreamtime
whale shark
in fact you're so amused by seeing the
whale shark earlier only to find one
painted here on the boat that it
distracts you
you don't realize that the whale shark
painting hadn't been on the side of the
boat when you'd shipped out
instead you pay the crew and thank the
captain for letting you hire the vessel
for your research and then head off
by the time you make it back to the
nearby town and settle down in after a
long day on the water
the dotted painting of the whale shark
has already slipped from your mind
but as you begin drifting off and
everything goes dark
you're about to find out that your
encounter with the dreamtime whale shark
is only just beginning you've never been
a heavy sleeper
and rarely remember your dreams any that
you might have
seem to pass out of your head the moment
you wake up or are too
faint for you to acknowledge while
you're sleeping but tonight is different
tonight you're dreaming vividly in this
dream water surrounds you
like it has your whole career but this
time
you're underneath the surface a drift in
an empty ocean
nothing around you but endless blank sea
you feel something in your hand
something smooth and moving gently like
organic matter
something alive you find yourself
gripping the tail of a whale shark
and somehow as is often the way with
dreams
you know that this is the same whale
shark from earlier that day
the one that swam up to your boat and
ended up sticking on the side of it as a
dot art painting
scp-1449 has this latent ability
while it normally appears as a flat
two-dimensional piece of aboriginal
australian dot art
the dreamtime whale shark can shift
whenever it is underwater
it still appears as a collection of
painted dots in this unmistakable shape
of a whale shark
but in an aquatic environment it becomes
three-dimensional
and that's what you'd seen swimming
towards the boat not just a whale shark
but scp-1449 within your dream you
released the dreamtime whale shark's
tail and begin to float upwards
breaking the surface of the water you
breathe lungfuls of fresh air
the first thing you see is land and it's
close by
close enough for you to swim to shore
battling through the water you reach an
island one in a chain of small land
masses
tiny continents in a shallow unfamiliar
ocean you look back to the water but can
find no
sign of scp-1449 the dreamtime whale
shark has
brought you here and left you on this
island but you can only speculate as to
why
there must be a reason you insist to
yourself the dreamscape around you it
would seem is either the creation of
scp-1449
where at the very least a side effect of
falling asleep close by
to where you saw the dreamtime whale
shark in its painted form
whatever this place is there must be
some way to uncover an
answer it stands to reason you think
that if you can understand what's going
on
then perhaps therein lies the key to
escaping this dream
and waking up back in reality
the small island you find yourself on
and the others nearby
are inhabited by strange life forms as
you walk across the shore
sand clinging to your wet feet you
approach what you thought at a distance
to be a group of
other people instead you see a group of
peculiar beings
they are not quite human but they are
definitely close
the closer you walk you notice these
strange humanoid shapes huddle tighter
together
their backs to you when you try to call
out to them asking where you are or how
you might return to reality
they bustle away the wind carries the
sound of their chatter towards you
and you're certain you hear them call
you another one
just another traveler from afar what you
don't realize
lost in this dream environment is that
there are others like it
pocket worlds like this one similar but
different
currently being experienced by any
others asleep near
scp-1449 as you ponder what to do
on the beach the captain of the boat you
hired is on a different version of the
same island
watching a herd of multiple 2 000 kilo
platypi
being shepherded by six tattooed three
meter tall
humanoid figures meanwhile his first
mate is in another version of this dream
world
learning how to hunt under the tutelage
of a man called grey the rabbit hunter
each version of scp-1449's dreamscape
have separate continuities to each other
they are differing copies of the same
chain of islands
with the same inhabitants but each
visited by a different traveler from
afar in their sleep
much like a lucid dream visitors to the
dream time whale sharks worlds can
interact with them
shaping and altering events in the
continuity they find themselves in
deciding to leave the beach you elect to
make your way towards higher ground
to try to get a wider scope of your
surroundings fortunately there is a
towering mountainous shape nearby
standing like dark serrated teeth
against the clear horizon
you begin your dangerous track ascending
your way up these dead jagged hills
you're still unclear on how you got here
or how to escape
but you will yourself to keep climbing
knowing there must be some way to wake
up from this bizarre dream
finally reaching level ground you take a
moment to catch your breath
collecting your thoughts before
advancing any further
you turn gazing out over the landscape
spreading out below
and all around you the island is small
enough you can see the shore where you
arrived
and the ocean flanking this landmass on
all sides
in this short moment you appreciate the
beauty of this bizarre dream world for
the first time
the trees sway and the gentle breeze
moving like the calm
rolling of waves in the water beyond
both glistening with the warm light of
the sun
while it is still true that you have no
idea how or why
scp-1449 brought you here or how to
leave
you think to yourself that at least this
dream environment isn't a hostile one
not that you'd want to be stranded there
forever but there are certainly far more
unforgiving places one can dream about
a grim thought suddenly dawns on you how
long have you been here
does time pass differently in this world
to the one you're still asleep in
as sound shakes your thoughts back to
your current here and now
it was a voice you're sure of it a voice
calling out
but not to you traversing the dead
jagged hills you see a figure
a person from the real world like you
not one of the local humanoids
they don't see you they're calling out
to someone in a random shackle hut
cobbled together from pieces of wood and
other scraps
on the arm of the figure's dark
military-like uniform is a symbol
and you can just make out three distinct
letters
s c p a wooden plank that functioned as
the door creaked open
revealing a second figure the man looks
disheveled
his worn clothing patched with scraps of
leather and shark's skin
making him looked as cobbled together as
his makeshift hut
like he was an extension of the small
structure he watches the man
talks to the agent overhearing his words
don't say anything
if you say anything i lose my mind you
can say anything and something horrible
happens
the strange man warns talking too
quickly for the foundation agent to
reply
you're a dreamer like me my name is
nikolai
i am the ship sierra of the dunham and
the brotherhood of selectrostic
the man nikolai he called himself seemed
distressed
tripping over his words disagreeing with
himself until he starts trailing off
into swearing obscenities
i'm not nikolai he shouts i am
agent john
before stumbling and cursing again i'm
sorry
i can't can't keep the memory straight
being dislocated for this long hurts
the dreaming fills in all the gaps
things have always been
even as they are brought into being i've
been on this cliff since the beginning
of time
just like how this place has always been
here the dream was torn away by the
deaths of gods before time began
but i watched it happen five years ago
are you following
[Music]
i can barely tell the dream and reality
apart anymore
my world has always been the way it is
and we made it like that
we hurt the dreaming the shark that's
how we see it
we heard it cued it in our world and the
dream time poured out like it spilled
blood and
we made this big scar here and
and things are wrong fish walk and
ghosts haunt the stones
and women give birth to plastic children
and the leech fields stretch out forever
in the seas of human blood and the
center eats cocaine and caviar out of
panda skull
bowls on the crush backs of opel mares
in acres of broken glass and it has
always been like this
don't don't do it don't do it again
you're already racing back down to the
dead jagged hills
the sight of the deranged nikolai burned
into your mind
a man reduced to a babbling lunatic cast
away and left alone in this strange
dreamscape that scp-1449
brought you to but nikolai is more than
that
more than just someone driven mad by his
isolation
he is a grim prophecy of what will
become of you
unless you can find a way to leave the
dreamtime whale sharks world
already back on the beach you drop down
kneeling in the wet sand as the tide
washes over your knees
the how or why of scp-1449 bringing you
into this dream isn't important
all that matters to you is avoiding
ending up like nikolai
whatever it takes you know one thing
above
all else you need to wake up
but whether you actually ever will is
another question
entirely now check out scp-343
god and scp-5000-y the full-story
compilation for more
mind-bending tales from the scp
foundation